les deux hommes d'une quarantaine
d'années qui se sont présentés
aujourd'hui à la barre avaient été
interpellés quelques mois après le
braquage des traces ADN retrouvé sur les
cordelettes utilisées pour ligoter les
vendeuses de la bijouterie les avait
confondu un élément qui n'est pas
irréfutable selon maître philpps scrve
avocat de l'un des accusés vous savez en
matière de d'ADN il faut être
extrêmement prudent l'ADN n'est pas une
preuve sur le plan scientifique c'est un
élément indiciare incontestable l'ADN ça
n'est pas ça n'est pas rien
naturellement ça n'est pas tout non plus
il faut apprécier les conditions dans
lesquelles des éléments génétiques ont
pu être trouvés l'avocat de la partie
civile compte lui bien insister sur ces
éléments qui lui apparaissent au
contraire ne faire aucun doute sur la
culpabilité de l'accusé comment le
laboratoire Biomnis sous la direction du
Professeur Van
denberg aurait pu se tromper franchement
alors je sais je sais que l'un des deux
accusés va tenter de dire qu'il n'y
était pour rien
à mon avis j'attends avec intérêt ces
explications le deuxième accusé a lui
reconnu les faits son avocat compte
plaider une enfance difficile et un
parcours chaotique pour obtenir une
moindre peine cette première journée ici
aux assises de Chalon sursun aura été un
long rappel des faits dans le box des
accusés deux hommes l'un écoute le juge
le regard froid l'autre paraît étonné
d'être là les de vendeuses violentées
pendant le braquage leur font face elles
se sont constitué parties civil dans ce
procès qui doit durer 5
jours